[Musique]
il ya ces dérives plus classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire ainsi internet on est moins
ceux des choses mystiques moins
religieuse comme on peut vous pouvez la
voir dans les 110 80 que sur des
phénomènes qui vont concerner la santé
ou l'alimentation et la crise du coc
vide à renforcer cette nouvelle porte
d'entrée dans les dérives sectaires ou
des goûts vous plutôt parler de
vaccination plutôt parler d'alimentation
plutôt parler de guérison au lieu
d'aller directement sur un terrain qui
sera un terrain religieux ou mystique on
retrouve par exemple dans les dernières
manifestations anti vaccins contre
locaux vides certains éléments qui se
rattachent à des mouvements à tendance
sectaire qui historiquement sont opposés
à toute vaccination
[Musique]
plus de 91 mille personnes contaminées
au coronavirus en moins de 24 heures en
france c'est un record depuis début
l'épidémie à la veille de noël les
français se ruent vers les tests de
dépistage le virus et ses variantes et
qui ont aussi largement impacté
l'économie française alors quel bilan
économique sur l'année 2021 on verra ça
avec notre économiste jacques satire
[Musique]
et ailleurs dans le monde nous couvre
feu fait son retour en catalogne en plus
du port du masque en extérieur dans
toute l'espagne et les pays bas sont
confinés jusqu'au 14 janvier prochain la
belgique vers des salles de spectacles
et l'italie var et imposer de nouvelles
mesures de restriction dans les jours à
venir aux états unis après la pilule de
phison heures celle du laboratoire merck
a été autorisé en urgence par l'agencé
américaine du médicament
[Musique]
est peut-être un premier pas pour
apaiser les tensions à la frontière
dans sa traditionnelle conférence de
presse de noël havel a dit mir poutine
estime que les premières réactions
américaines sont positifs quant aux
dernières exigences de la russie est si
washington se dit prêt à dialoguer avec
moscou londres condamnent la rhétorique
russe mais salue la volonté de dialoguer
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
plus de 91 me le cas positifs au
coronavirus en moins de 24 heures en
france jamais le pays n'avait connu de
pareils chiffres depuis le début de la
pandémie en une seule journée est la
situation est préoccupante et emmanuel
macron s'est exprimé ce matin sur ses
réseaux sociaux est le chef de l'état
invite les français à se faire dépister
avant les fêtes de fin d'année ils sont
nombreux ces derniers jours à se rendre
dans les centres de dépistage du pays et
dans la semaine du 13 au 19 décembre
dernier plus de 6 millions de tests ont
été validés et ce soir c'est olivier
ferrand qui s'est exprimé devant les
caméras pour faire un point justement
sur la situation
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
bons ils sont même les pires chiffres
enregistrés en termes de contamination
depuis le début de la pandémie se sait
de mémoire 88 mille cas positifs qui ont
été enregistrés nous testons beaucoup
donc nous trouvons beaucoup mais très
clairement nous constatons en france ce
que nous constatons dans tous les pays
qui sont touchés par ce variant mikron
extrêmement contagieux avec un
doublement du nombre de cas positifs
quasiment tous les deux jours ce qui
veut dire que j'avais parlé de 100 mille
cas positifs par jour entre noël et
nouvel an peut-être même que ce sera
très près de noël davantage plus près de
noël que du nouvel ange un appel d'
emmanuel macron alors que le conseil
scientifique alerte cet après midi sur
l'absentéisme au travail due aux
nombreux cas positif qui pourrait
désorganiser le pays une mise en garde
qui intervient à quatre jours d'un
conseil à des ministres extraordinaire
un rendez vous lundi lors duquel sera
étudié le pass vaccinale il mesure que
dénoncent les restaurateurs et nombre
d'entre eux conteste devoir contrôler
l'identité de leurs clients il estime ne
pas être habilités à le faire et renvoie
la balle aux policiers écoutez justement
à christophe schirach et les
restaurateurs et vice-président du
syndicat antigone ou c'est absolument
pas mettre travail so lu ment pas taire
quand on monte les gens les gens les uns
contre les autres c'est classique depuis
le début de cette crise voilà donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer on va
provoquer des bagarres à l'entraidé des
restaurants on va cliquer légitimité
romain dans tout ça qu'est ce qu'on a je
veux dire endettement
ce qu'on a à [ __ ] dans ce problème
dans ce débat voilà on n'a rien à faire
dans cette histoire encore une fois on
est les objets d'une politique on est
des pantins on a utilisé et on n'a rien
à faire dans tout ça on n'a rien à
contrôler ses de ces débiles bon si ça
fonctionnait cette saurait se passe si
l'épave il est pas ça ni taire tout le
monde la reconnaît y compris les pelures
de membres du gouvernement
stop on arrête quand il s'agit de faire
du sanitaire on est les premiers et
aucun problème en a on n'a pas du tout
envie ni d'être malade ni que nos
clients soient malades on a envie de les
revoir donc on n'a aucun problème avec
ça mais qu'on arrête de nous
instrumentaliser très honnêtement je
pense que l'on va finir par vraiment se
fâcher et pour notre éditorialiste à
nicolas vidal le gouvernement joue sur
les peurs des français
ce qui me choque c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la dramatisation c'est
lui shakespeare la galerie est atteint
jean castex odile et veyran il ya une
scénarisation je vais vous le dire tout
de go de la panique en ce moment sur ce
variant au micro et on a le retour on a
le retour vous l'avez dit conseil
scientifique mais non retour sur les
plateaux des chaînes ce crime du ce que
j'appelle des gangs des enfers mist qui
sont là pour nous parler pour certains
issus sur du bout des lèvres un
confinement et puis vous avez cette
pression mais il entendu les contraintes
vous me posez la question mais les
pressions inadmissibles et outrancière
jamais vous dire sur noël et finalement
qu'est ce que ça cache tout ça parce que
ça cache qui fait que ça cache qu'est ce
que ça nous incite à penser c'est que
finalement le gouvernement est dans une
perspective de stratégie maximale de
vaccination est aussi ne l'oublions pas
disons le aussi une discrimination
officielle finalement des non vaccinés
et quel bilan économique tirées de cette
année 2021 une année de forte reprise
après le choc déconfinement de 2020 elle
met les variants du coc vie dont le
dernier en date omicron sont venus jouer
les trouble-fête aujourd'hui elle le
gouvernement parle toujours d'une année
de croissance
exceptionnelle avec un chômage qui
continue de baisser mais qui est il
derrière tout cela l'activité est elle
toujours aussi vigoureuse en cette fin
d'année on en parle justement avec notre
économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir jacky alors à quel est le bilan
économique quel bilan économique peut-on
tirer de cette année et question
subsidiaire
le gouvernement peut-il vraiment crier
victoire comme il le fait actuellement
le bilan est nécessairement très
contrastées alors pour les actionnaires
des entreprises qui sont cotées en
bourse qui sont au cac 40 ça a été une
excellente année c'est clair maintenant
pour le reste de la population c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus difficile pour
la question prend simplement la qualité
de la croissance et pour les
travailleurs
ce n'est pas du tout évident que c était
une bonne année et il faut rappeler que
2021 aurait dû être l'année d'un espèce
de retour à la normale en tous les cas
c'est ce que l'on pensait justement fin
2020 mais il y avait justement les
variants les divers variant britannique
indien et maintenant le vario au micron
et que ça devait être aussi une année où
l'on aurait pris conscience des
problèmes de l'économie française tels
qu'ils se sont révélés par l'aco vider
la crise sanitaire or on voit bien le
constat va être assez différents et
jacques faut d'abord que penser des
affirmations du gouvernement qui vante
une croissance historique accompagnée
d'une forte mais les chômages
alors il est clair que nous sommes dans
une année électorale ça n'aura échappé à
personne
donc ces affirmations sont peut-être à
prendre avec une certaine prudence ce
qui est évident c'est que nous avons une
croissance en 2021 qui a été forte oui
bien sûr mais elle est venue après une
chute du pib qui a été peut-être plus
sévères en france que dans des pays
limitrophes ou un peu plus loin timbre
plus sévère en allemagne en suède aux
états unis on doit ajouter que cette
croissance n'est pas la plus forte de
l'après guerre contrairement à ce que
bruno le maire avait pu affirmer nous
avons tenu déjà des taux identiques dans
les années 60 ensuite le point important
et on le voit sur le graphique c'est que
cette croissance qui est attendu pour 6
7% pour cette année est bien n'est pas
suffisante pour effacer les -8 2% de
récession que l'on a connu en 2020 du
fait de la crise sanitaire et on peut le
dire d'ailleurs à peu près la même chose
en ce qui concerne l'évolution du taux
de chômage là aussi le gouvernement est
très fier de cette évolution est ce que
l'on peut constater c'est que si la
baisse est réelle et forte pour la
catégorie ya comme on le voit là encore
sur le graphique et bien il n'en va pas
de même si on regarde non plus cette
catégorie diable mais l'agrégat qui est
beaucoup plus représentatif du phénomène
du chômage et qui est l'agrégat des
différentes catégories à b et d alors là
nous sommes loin d'être revenue au
niveau du quatrième trimestre
2010 9 comme c'est le cas pour la simple
catégorie a et on voit aussi que si on
prend cette fois ci le quasi chômage qui
représentait dans les statistiques par
les catégories c e de pôle emploi eh
bien on voit que ce que ce quasi chômage
continue lui à augmenter régulièrement
donc la baisse du chômage dont se
prévaut aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
bien elle est largement en trompe l'oeil
par contre jacques 2021 a été une bonne
année pour les actionnaires ah oui là on
peut même parler d'un véritable crue
historique
si vous voulez non seulement les cours
de la bourse ont effacé la chute de mars
2020 qui était consécutive à la crise
sanitaire
mais ils ont même largement pulvérisé le
plus haut historique de la bourse
autrement dit on est passé au delà des
7000 points alors cela est dû à la
politique monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne elle a comme
d'ailleurs la fed américaine ou la
banque d'angleterre elle adopter une
politique très expansionniste pour
contrer justement les effets dépressifs
de la crise sanitaire le résultat était
un afflux de liquidités sur les marchés
financiers
et cet afflux a provoqué justement en
partie la montée spectaculaire des
indices dont le cac 40 évidemment alors
il faut aussi voir les effets induits de
cette situation le premier effet induit
c'est que les opérateurs ont perdu le
sens du risque et il faut donc faire
attention parce que cette hausse qui
provoque un sentiment de reliques de
richesse elle provoque un sentiment de
richesse qui peut être factice alors
c'est en particulier le cas aux états
unis et là il faut toujours se souvenir
qu'il ya un nombre très élevé de ménage
qui détiennent des actions environ 70%
c'est peut-être moins le cas en france
où il n'y a que 12 % environ des ménages
qui détiennent des actions mais ce
sentiment de risque qui a été perdu par
les investisseurs eh bien il va aussi
jouer de manière importante sur les
différents fonds qui opère depuis la
france mais jacques cette politique des
banques centrales n'est-elle pas la
cause de l'inflation que l'on connaît
depuis cet été
oui pierre là vous avez vous posé une
vraie question alors c'est vrai d'abord
qu'on connaît une forte inflation
environ 3% en france en cette fin
d'année au-delà de 5% en allemagne
environ 7% aux etats-unis
simplement ce pic d'inflation n'est pas
directement liée aux politiques des
banques centrales cette inflation l
ailier ne forte montée des coûts parce
que le système d approvisionnement le
commerce mondial globalement est encore
très largement perturbée par là que
vivent 19 et de fait l'année 2021
restera l'année des pénuries alors pour
les matières premières est évidemment je
pense au pétrole mais pas que le blé
aussi a été touchée mais aussi pour les
produits manufacturés est la pénurie est
forte par exemple pour les semi
conducteurs au point de provoquer des
arrêts de production dans l'automobile
et des hausses de prix importantes dans
le secteur c'est ainsi que l'on explique
le fait en apparence étranges que la
hausse des prix est était nettement plus
importante en allemagne qu'en france
maintenant il faut aussi se dire que
l'inflation est sans doute là pour durer
et c'est en particulier le résultat de
la transition énergétique qui fera de
tout manière monter les coûts et donc ce
que l'on peut dire c'est que 2021
pourrait bien avoir été l'année où nous
avons renoué avec le phénomène de
l'inflation mais alors jacques les
françaises sont ils plus enrichis ou
appauvri en 2021
bien virer que les riches se sont
enrichis les bourses se sont appauvris
alors les plus riches c'est évident ils
ont profité de cette année les
portefeuilles boursiers on joue un rôle
très important dans ce mouvement on sait
aussi que l'épargné accumulée pendant
les différents confinement de 2020 et du
début de 2021 et bien certains ce
n'était pas un miraculé a été
massivement accumulées par les 10% des
ménages les plus riches alors qu'au
contraire les 30 % les plus pauvres ont
des épargnes et on sait aussi que le
nombre de gens qui ont recours
aujourd'hui à l'aide alimentaire aux
organisations caritatives
ce qui est dit par exemple par le
secours catholique le secours populaire
bien ce nombre de gens a beaucoup
augmenté le secours catholique par
exemple annonce des chiffres qui serait
compris entre 8 et 9 millions de
personnes on a vu aussi autre point
important
qu'une partie des étudiants pratiquement
un quart des étudiants avaient désormais
recours à cette aide alimentaire donc
nous avons un véritable problème
problème qui se mesure aussi avec le
fait que 20 % des enfants sont sous le
seuil de pauvreté et donc 2021 pourrait
aussi rester dans nos mémoires comme
l'année où les inégalités ont explosé
donc la conclusion c'est une année en
demi-teinte 1 pour les français oui en
demi teinte en moyenne mais ça a été une
année brillante pour les plus riches et
une année noire pour les plus pauvres et
ça voyez vous c'est un problème qui va
peser sur les comportements politiques
la question sociale la question des
inégalités la question du partage des
richesses tu pourrais bien faire
aujourd'hui son grand retour alors même
si actuellement nous sommes plutôt
partagés entre l'inquiétude au sujet
d'un nouveau rien et des nouvelles
plutôt rassurantes
issu de la vaccination mais aussi de
l'analyse qui est faite de ce nouveau
variant est bien il ne faut pas oublier
l'essentiel c'est le grand retour de la
question sociale et c'est cela peut-être
qui va marquer 2021 merci beaucoup
jacques sapir pour ce bilan échos de
2021 bonne fête à vous et à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouvel édito échos
merci et face à l'augmentation des cas
partout dans le monde les pays sont
nombreux phares et imposer de nouvelles
restrictions en espagne le masque
devient obligatoire en extérieur et le
couvre feu fait son retour en catalogne
les précisions à barcelone de clémentine
or dès demain ce sera le retour des
masques dans les rues c'est la décision
qu'a prise le gouvernement espagnol pour
faire face à la hausse alarmante de cas
de kobe 19 dans le pays alors depuis
plusieurs semaines le nombre de cas
explose ici en espagne et a même battu
le record de contamination en un jour ce
mercredi plus de soixante mille cas ont
été enregistrés
le taux d'incidence de son côté continue
de grimper il n'avait jamais été aussi
élevée que depuis février dernier la
région de la catalogne est
particulièrement touchée et certains de
ces hôpitaux se disent au bord de la
saturation
c'est pour cela que le tribunal
supérieur de justice catalan a décidé de
valider les mesures prises par le
gouvernement régional alors à partir de
ce jeudi soir minuit les rassemblements
sociaux seront limitées à 10 personnes
les discothèques devront fermer et on
devrait imposer une jauge d'occupation
dans les établissements de 50 % dans la
restauration est de 70 % dans le reste
des établissements accueillant du public
c'est aussi le retour du couvre feu de
1h à 6 heures du matin pour environ 125
villes catalanes alors après que la
catalogne a annoncé ces nouvelles
restrictions le gouvernement espagnol a
décidé lui aussi d'imposer des mesures
et mais cette fois ci c'est pour tout le
territoire espagnol la ministre de la
santé carolyn arias a imposé le retour
du port obligatoire du masque à
l'extérieur et ce à partir de vendredi
et mme fatiha
je tiens à souligner qu'il s'agit d'une
mesure temporaire
une mesure temporaire aussi long tant
qu'elle est nécessaire jusqu'à ce que la
situation épidémiologique dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons s'améliore ainsi avec
cette nouvelle réglementation disons que
le port du masque dans nos rues est à
nouveau obligatoire sauf pour quelques
exceptions qui sont dans le cadre de la
pratique d'un sport individuel est
également dans les espèces naturelles
lors d'activités non sportives pour
autant que la distance d'un mètre
cinquante puisse être resté à distance
ya de nos consignes alors face à cette
sixième vague de coved 19 le
gouvernement espagnol mise tout sur la
vaccination il a fait appel à l'armée
pour injecter plus de doses à la
population pour l'instant presque hui
espagnols sur dix ont reçu deux doses
d'un autre côté la vaccination des
enfants a commencé et les personnes de
plus de 60 ans peuvent recevoir une
troisième injection
et embellit les théâtres et les salles
de spectacles doivent fermer leurs
portes décision du gouvernement fédéral
qui agace les professionnels du secteur
de la culture est les patrons de théâtre
sont consternés et sont surtout inquiets
pour l'avenir de leur établissement
écoutez les
évidemment on est abasourdi cette
décision est épouvantable et surtout
désastreuse pour nos artistes pour nos
maisons et pour les publics d'autant que
elle résulte surtout d'une d'une
instrumentalisation politique puisque ce
comité de concertation a pris cette
décision
absurde sans tenir compte de l'avis des
experts scientifiques qui voulait
poursuivre les activités dans le secteur
culturel personne ne comprend pour qu'on
pénalise à culture qui était un des
lieux les plus sécurisés dans le pays
donc ça n'a aucun sens donc il ya un
vrai sentiment de révolte au temps dès
le départ j'ai soutenu la difficulté du
monde politique à trouver des solutions
et j'ai soutenu les ministres là
maintenant j'en ai marre et l'australie
ci n'échappe pas non plus à
l'augmentation des cas de co vide et à
la présence du vario mikron pour tenter
de contrer l'épidémie la nouvelle galles
du sud région de sydney de nouvelles
restrictions sont également mises en
place et des mesures qu'ils viennent
contredire celle annoncée par le premier
ministre australien marion caudal et
juliette lamy
le port du masque obligatoire de retour
à l'intérieur conséquence d'un pic
d'infection duo coronavirus avec 5715
nouveaux cas en 24 heures la nouvelle
galles du sud est l'état le plus touché
en australie un nombre presque
équivalent à celui enregistré la veille
dans tout le pays le premier ministre de
l'état concernés a annoncé plusieurs
mesures à
partir de minuit ce soir nous exigerons
le port de masques dont les
environnements intérieurs nous
encourageons les gens en particulier
pendant la période des vacances à
travailler de chez eux s'ils le peuvent
nous voulons limiter la mobilité pendant
cette période et on particulier pour
nous assurer que nos travailleurs de la
santé sont en mesure de travailler et de
fournir les soins et le soutien
nécessaire aux personnes malades
plus au sud l'état de victoria a aussi
modifié la réglementation sur le port du
masque dès ce jeudi les personnes âgées
de plus de 8 ans devront en porter un
dans les bureaux les lieux d'accueil et
de divertissement un renforcement des
mesures sanitaires qui contraste avec la
politique du gouvernement fédéral lors
d'une réunion entre les dirigeants des
états australiens et le premier ministre
scott morrison à rejeter le port
généralisé du masque à l'intérieur
selon lui un confinement n'est pas
envisageable non plus il serait trop
contraignant pour la population
le cabinet national a conduit une
approche positive en ce qui concerne ce
qu'on appelle la santé publique et les
mesures sociales ou essentiellement la
façon dont les gens interagissent les
uns avec les autres de sorte qu'ils sont
plus en sécurité mais ils sont toujours
en mesure de poursuivre leur vie et je
pense que c'est une preuve très
importante que le cabinet national
fournit des résultats plus sûres mais
sans contraindre la vie des gens
le 15 décembre dernier l'australie à
lever un certain nombre de restrictions
noté celles imposées aux voyageurs qui
peuvent désormais se rendre sur place à
condition d'avoir reçu deux doses de
vaccin anti qu'ovide
une lueur d'espoir pour tenter d'apaiser
les tensions à la frontière ukrainienne
les etats unis se disent prêts à
dialoguer avec la russie pour éviter
nouvelle guerre froide est de son côté
vladimir poutine estime que les premiers
réaction américaine aux exigences du
kremlin sont positives le dialogue c'est
aussi ce que c'est lui londres
aujourd'hui le point avec notre
correspondant à moscou entonne clients
près de quatre heures et cinquante cinq
questions pour cette traditionnelle
conférence de presse de vladimir poutine
qui a donc eu le temps d'aborder de très
nombreuses thématiques même si plusieurs
questions rapidement évoqué la
problématique ukrainienne vladimir
poutine a constaté le manque de volonté
politique de la part de kiev concernant
la mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk
et le président russe a assuré une
nouvelle fois que la russie ne menacer
personne et qu'elle cherchait uniquement
assurer sa propre sécurité à ce titre il
averti qu'une nouvelle extension de
l'otan vers l'est étaient tout
simplement inconcevable j'ai vu qu'un
des éléments principaux aujourd'hui
c'est la stabilité
sur cette partie du terrain et nous
devons comprendre comment assurer de
cette sécurité donc ici sans aucune ruse
nous avons cette question ouvertement il
ne doit y avoir aucun mouvement de
l'otan en direction de l'est c'est à
dire que la balle est dans leur camp
c'est eux qui doivent répondre
maintenant à cet égard d'ailleurs je
voudrais souligner aussi que dans
l'ensemble nous avons vu une réaction
positive
nos partenaires américains ont se sont
dits prêts à commencer des discussions
dès le début de l'année prochaine à
jeunes les représentants des deux
parties ont été nommés et j'espère bien
qu'on va continuer sur cette voie
concernant la loi sur les agents de
l'étranger cette loi qui limite le
travail de certains médias en russie
vladimir poutine a tenu à faire ça voir
qu'il s'agissait à la base d'une loi
américaine et que les autorités russes
n'avaient fait que répliquer que
répondre de façon symétrique à cette loi
américaine concrètement il s'agit
simplement pour ses organes de déclarer
leurs sources de financement
et au final relativement peu de médias
sont concernés nous ne demandons qu'une
chose c'est d'indiquer la source de
votre financement il ya une question qui
est lié à l'implication politique ici
qui est liée à la réglementation du
travail oui nous avons 74 organisations
qui étaient considérés comme agent de
l'étranger sur 200 milles qui sont
enregistrés chez nous donc c'est 0 0 34%
donc on n'a même pas une rhétorique
aussi sévère que là bas aux états unis
tout au long de cette conférence de
presse il a été question de cette
pandémie que nous traversons des
questions à la dimension parfois locales
tel ou tel problème dans telle ou telle
région de russie et des questions à la
dimension nationale à propos des mesures
économiques et sociales adoptées par les
autorités pour soutenir l'économie et
l'emploi l'emploi véritable priorité
dans la lutte des autorités russes
contre le coc vie 19 il était question
également de la crise du gaz va dire
poutine a rappelé que gazprom livrer
tous les volumes promis qu'il honorait
tous ses contrats et elle est même
parfois au delà en fournissant des
volumes de gaz supplémentaires et ce qui
va à l'encontre des accusations
occidentales qui sous-entendent que
gazprom livre moins de gaz que prévu il
était question de très nombreux autres
thématiques telles que la démographie
l'inflation est bien entendu des
situations locales dans telle ou telle
région de russie au final une conférence
de presse extrêmement dense aux
thématiques abordées extrêmement variés
qui a fait malgré tout la part belle aux
problématiques nationales sans oublier
de rappeler les lignes rouges de la
russie concernant les grands thèmes de
l'actualité internationale que son
l'ukraine les relations avec washington
mais aussi l'otan l'ouverture au
dialogue donc entre les états unis et la
russie pour claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales une série
de pourparlers entre
uc américain est attendu ces prochaines
semaines les deux parties devraient
d'ailleurs se retrouver à genève dès le
mois de janvier
ce que veut le président de la russie
c'est une garantie de sécurité de la
part des états unis et dans un premier
temps en tout cas de personne d'autre il
en a d'ailleurs parlé à joe biden dans
l'entretien qu'ils ont eu par voie
numérique et
apparemment effectivement il a obtenu
que joe biden désigne un négociateur de
haut niveau
monsieur poutine a également désigné un
négociateur de haut niveau et les deux
se rencontreront des vues début janvier
à genève ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
groupe à haut niveau qui discutera de
l'établissement de conditions de
sécurité pour la russie mais aussi pour
les états unis bien entendu et on
reprend les négociations d'armes ce
contrôle c'est déjà ce que monsieur
poutine avait obtenu le 15 juin à genève
lorsqu'il avait obtenu que tous les
traités qui avait été détricoté par
chuck des traités d'armes ce contrôle
entre la russie et les etats unis
puissent revoir le jour sous une forme
ou sous une autre
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous l'avoir suivi le prochain point sur
l'actualité elle ce sera dans un peu
plus de trente minutes restez bien sûr
avec nous sur arte france je vous dis
halte là
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années dont on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qui l'attend